oye mi sol políticos presentamos la
historia más 2021 de todo el año 2021
miles de solicitantes de asilo iraquíes
en la frontera de polonia con
bielorrusia y diréis pero qué tiene de
especial pues vamos a ver mirad este
mapa mira que está aquí bielorrusia está
aquí y polonia está aquí estáis pensando
lo mismo que yo que pintan unos iraquíes
cruzando la frontera entre bielorrusia y
polonia
pues de eso es de lo que vamos a hablar
en este vídeo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
lo que tenemos es lo siguiente desde el
lado bielorruso hasta 7000 iraquíes pero
también se encuentran sirios iraníes
afganos libaneses están en la frontera y
lo que quieren es entrar en la unión
europea por donde pues por los tres
países de la unión europea que tienen la
dudosa suerte de ser vecinos de
bielorrusia hablamos de polonia lituania
y letonia y como os podéis imaginar a
ninguno de ellos le hace la más mínima
gracia ver de repente a toda esa gente
en su frontera y para colmo no es que
estemos hablando precisamente de paz y
armonía atentos
[Música]
la violencia está ahí en la frontera
entre polonia y bielorrusia cuando los
guardias por la corte para en cañones de
agua contra migrantes que arrojan
piedras exacto aquí tenemos una lluvia
de piedras por un lado y cañones de agua
y gases lacrimógenos por el otro los
migrantes intentan tirar abajo los
puestos fronterizos polonia está
reforzando la frontera lituania está
empezado a construir un muro de
alambrada al más puro estilo donald
trump más barato y la otan se plantea
intervenir y todo esto se ha
desarrollado en menos de un mes
vamos que en los 1200 kilómetros de
frontera entre bielorrusia y león'
europea se ha concentrado tantísima
acción que a su lado la última película
de james bond parece de un maratón de
las chicas gilmore y me diréis vamos a
ver fonseca no lo estás pintando como
una crisis macro nacho vitaliana pero
seamos claros 7000 personas para tres
países pues tampoco es para tanto verdad
al fin y al cabo sólo en el año 2015 la
unión europea recibía más de un millón
de solicitud de asilo y ahí sigue europa
bueno pues decírselo al primer ministro
de polonia ladies and sons of man peter
tuyo me cause europe tal como nach aun
strachan como veis para polonia lo que
está pasando en su frontera es una
declaración de guerra en toda regla y si
hablamos del mismo morawiecki que hace
dos meses estaba diciendo que bruselas
le hacía chantaje sin embargo ahora lo
vemos apelando a esos valores comunes
europeos nada que nos sorprenda es la
típica relación amor-odio varsovia y
bruselas pasa una vez cada dos meses
[Música]
ahora bien en cualquier caso polonia no
sería la única víctima de esta historia
porque en el momento en el que estamos
grabando este vídeo al menos 13
migrantes han perdido ya la vida y
recordad que hablamos también de
familias niños incluso recién nacidos y
todo esto en un invierno el crudo
invierno centroeuropeo un niño de 14
años muere de frío en la frontera de
bielorrusia mientras los migrantes están
siendo usados como armas en una crisis
cada vez mayor y la pregunta que os
estáis haciendo es uno usados como armas
por quién quién es el malo malísimo
detrás de esta historia el genio del mal
detrás de todo esto dos qué narices
pintan unos iraquíes cruzando
concretamente la frontera entre polonia
y bielorrusia y tres donde están ahora
cuál ha sido el desenlace de todo esto
ha sido una de estas historias de las
que mañana ni nos acordaremos o de
verdad debería preocuparnos hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
el hombre que quería ser supervillano
ya sé lo que estáis pensando algunos
seguro que rusia tiene que estar aquí
metida porque claro hablamos de
bielorrusia ese país que normalmente por
sí solo seamos honestos tampoco es que
mueva los hilos de la política
internacional y efectivamente hay gente
hay analistas que dicen que todo esto
que está pasando ahora en la frontera
bielorrusa es parte de un gran plan de
nuestro buen amigo vladimir putin un
plan de putin para desestabilizar europa
cerca rusia sea grande de nuevo y
dominar el mundo pero lo cierto es que
al menos técnicamente no tiene mucho
sentido que esta crisis bielorrusas esté
orquestando de este moscú es más no
sería la primera vez que bielorrusia se
impone a los intereses de su gran
hermano ruso y la experiencia nos
demuestra que el señor alexander
lukashenko se sobra y se basta para
crear conflictos internacionales
[Música]
y alguno se preguntará pero pero quiénes
lukashenko pues bien para los que seáis
nuevos en visual política y todavía no
os hayáis visto todos los vídeos que
hemos hecho sobre bielorrusia os voy a
hacer un spoiler bielorrusia es una
dictadura es más es la última gran
dictadura de europa pero lo mejor de
todo es que ni siquiera lo intentan
disimular es más todo lo contrario si
algún día se inventa el día del orgullo
dictador lukashenko será la reina de la
cabalgata atentos es mejor ser un
dictador que gay declara el presidente
de bielorrusia si habéis oído bien os
presento a alexander lukashenko algunos
niños querían ser astronautas de mayor o
youtubers pues bien él quería ser
dictador
infinita pero tal cual como lo oís os lo
voy a decir aún más claro alexandr
lukashenko es un señor que de pequeño
quería ser supervillano y dentro de lo
que cabe pues no le ha salido nada mal
es más ha llegado a ser el dictador el
orgulloso dictador de un país de 9
millones de habitantes
[Música]
diego el poder hace ya 27 años y le ha
gustado tanto que ha decidido quedarse a
ser posible para siempre y claro como
hay una parte cada vez más grande de la
población que no está conforme con vivir
en una dictadura no me digáis porque en
los últimos años el régimen bielorruso
ha ido cerrándose progresivamente
primero empezaron previendo las
protestas con multas detenciones cargas
policiales y represiones varias segundo
continuaron restringiendo aún más si
cabía la libertad de prensa a día de hoy
hay varios medios de comunicación que o
bien se han tenido que cerrar o bien no
se puede acceder a ellos desde
bielorrusia hablamos de una ofensiva en
toda regla
periodistas bien los rusos condenados a
dos años de cárcel por transmitir las
protestas en directo
y un sitio de noticias leído por más del
40% de los usuarios de internet
bielorruso ha sido bloqueado y sus
editores interrogados después de una
redada en sus oficinas y casas con todo
esto nos debería sorprender que
bielorrusia sea el país con menos
libertad de prensa en toda europa si
incluso les va peor que a turquía y yo
os podéis imaginar cómo funciona la
política en este país
[Música]
sin ir más lejos las últimas elecciones
presidenciales se celebraron en agosto
del año pasado en un principio la cosa
pintaba sorprendentemente bien
obviamente él lukashenko era el
candidato principal pero en la papeleta
provisional también había varios nombres
de la oposición que tenían bastante
apoyo popular es más incluso había
analistas que decían oye pues a lo mejor
es el momento para que haya una
transición en este país un nuevo
presidente y quizás hasta elecciones
libres y democráticas y si seguís visual
político desde hace tiempo ya sabéis lo
que ocurrió porque le dedicamos todo un
vídeo en su momento por cierto que este
es un momento fantástico para recordaros
que os tro escribáis este canal y que
echéis un vistazo a nuestro patrio
[Música]
i
ya sabéis que si nos apoyáis en patrón
no sólo estaréis colaborando con este
proyecto sino que además recibiréis
acceso a nuestra newsletter semanal
donde os mandamos análisis de política
internacional que no encontraréis en
ningún otro medio de comunicación cosas
como las protestas de cuba la inflación
en eeuu o las últimas noticias de corea
del norte vamos que si queréis estar
bien informados el patrón de visual
político es el resumen semanal perfecto
y además estaréis ayudando a hacer
crecer esta comunidad dicho de otra
forma que es el 2 por uva pero volvamos
a nuestra historia de hoy
[Música]
por si no recordáis lo que ocurrió en
las últimas elecciones bielorrusia aquí
tenéis un resumen en tres noticias
bielorrusia prohíbe a dos candidatos de
la oposición presentarse a las
elecciones
representantes de la oposición
bielorrusa detenidos antes de las
elecciones presidenciales
elecciones en bielorrusia la líder de la
oposición tica no pesca ya se fue por el
bien de sus hijos como os podéis
imaginar cuando llegó el día de las
elecciones ni las protestas ni la
presión internacional han valido para
garantizar un nivel mínimo de
transparencia y con esto lukashenko
empezó su sexto mandato siendo más
dictador que nunca para que nos
entendamos a día de hoy en las cárceles
bielorrusas hay hasta 800 presos
políticos y nadie se queda a salvo
porque el régimen de lukashenko tiene
los brazos muy pero que muy largos
atentos a una de las noticias más
surrealistas de este año un vuelo de
ryanair con un periodista de la
oposición se ve obligado a aterrizar en
bielorrusia habéis oído bien bajo una
amenaza de bomba falsa bielorrusia
secuestro un avión de ryanair que estaba
volando de grecia a lituania solo para
bajar a un periodista opositor y
llevárselo a la cárcel y si habéis oído
bien un avión de ryanair así que ya lo
podéis apuntar para la próxima vez que
toméis un vuelo nada de quejaros de si
la siento no es cómodo o si no os dejan
subir la maleta dad las gracias de que
no os haya secuestrado bielorrusia sólo
por esto lukashenko ya se merece un
premio al supervillano del año una
mención en nuestro vídeo a los peores
políticos del año pero en esta vida todo
se puede superar cuál dirías que ha sido
su plan definitivo la estrategia que
podríamos dar un premio a vidas de ollas
dictatoriales del año 2021 pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
y va para listo y se quedó en listillo
antes de esta hablar de esta idea del
siglo os tengo que decir una cosa
obviamente las artimañas de lukashenko
no sólo tienen un impacto en bielorrusia
pensar de nuevo en aquel vuelo de
ryanair hasta mayo de este año nadie se
pensaba que un país por muy dictadura
que fuera pudiera atreverse a secuestrar
de esta manera un avión comercial que
sobrevuela su espacio aéreo claro está
que la unión europea y otros países no
se quedaron de brazos cruzados lo que se
hace en estos casos es imponer sanciones
comerciales y otras medidas por el
estilo hablamos por ejemplo de un
embargo de armas y embargo de bienes que
podrían usarse para la represión pero
sobre todo hablamos de sanciones con
nombre y apellidos contra los 166
representantes del régimen de lukashenko
ahora mismo sus activos están congelados
y no pueden viajar a la unión europea o
transitar por ella obviamente el propio
alexander lukashenko es uno de estos
sancionados además de que la unión
europea no reconoció oficialmente su
gobierno
[Música]
dicho de otra forma creo que ya os
podéis imaginar cómo es la dinámica
bielorrusia da un pasito más hacia una
dictadura perfecta y la unión europea
responde con un paquete de sanciones
bielorrusia sigue reprimiendo a las
periodistas y entonces europa pone otro
paquete de sanciones pacíficas
elecciones u otro paquete de sanciones
secuestrar un avión u otro paquete de
sanciones y aquí tenemos al señor
lukashenko sufriendo con el quiero y no
puedo porque si alguien pensaba que ser
un dictador megalómano es fácil se
equivoca
por un lado lukashenko quiere tener la
última palabra porque necesita proyectar
una imagen fuerte tanto de cara a la
población que todavía le apoya como
hacia el exterior pero por el otro
decidme qué creéis que puede hacer
bielorrusia contra la unión europea y es
entonces cuando este hombre en su afán
de ser un genio del mal dijo vamos a ver
cómo puedo yo atacar a la unión europea
para vengarme un poco de todas estas
sanciones comerciales y a ser posible
obligarles a sentarse en la mesa conmigo
y reconocerme como presidente vamos a
ver puedo atacarles con mi ejército
evidentemente no puedo mandarles
terroristas tampoco puedo hacer una
guerra comercial como he hecho putin
alguna vez con el gas natural
pues no porque bielorrusia no vende
muchas cosas a europa y aquí es cuando
nos acercamos al punto álgido de este
proceso mental no sé si es que
lukashenko se ha visto gambito de dama o
si se ha creído un estratega o si es que
lo ha soñado pero lo que vais a ver
ahora de verdad os prometo que ha
ocurrido en la vida real atentos el
dictador a bielorrusia amenaza con
inundar la unión europea con drogas
inmigrantes
señor sí señor nos parece una idea de
supervillano de película porque es que
además sé que parece difícil pero es que
cuando a lukashenko se le antoja algo
nada es imposible
[Música]
atentos a la jugada paso número 1 para
organizar una crisis migratoria lo
mínimo que necesitas son los propios
migrantes verdad y si no los tienes a
mano te los tienes que traer como
atentos organizando toda una campaña de
publicidad en los países en los que la
gente tiene muchas razones para creer
marcharse países como irak siria líbano
afganistán y otras zonas calientes basta
con convencerles con promesas como esta
información falsa difundida a menudo en
el pasado incluía que cada refugiado
recibe un pago de bienvenida de dos mil
euros habéis oído bien una paga de
bienvenida en alemania un trabajo
garantizado en la unión europea son
algunas de las promesas que lukashenko
ha hecho para atraer a todos estos
migrantes siempre habíamos oído que los
políticos prometen cosas que no pueden
cumplir lo que nunca nos imaginábamos
era políticos prometiendo cosas que van
a hacer supuestamente otros políticos
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque la cosa
no se queda aquí paso 2 vamos con la
logística como traemos a toda esta gente
a las puertas de la unión europea pues
muy fácil emitiendo visados turísticos
vio los rusos como si no hubiera mañana
una vez los tengamos colocamos a todos
estos turistas en aviones irlandeses
operados por una compañía aérea
bielorrusa cuando llegan a bielorrusia
los traemos a las fronteras y les
decimos por donde tienen que ir para
cruzar la frontera con polonia y llegar
hasta la tierra prometida alemán e igual
a aquí tenéis el truco de magia el súper
plan maléfico de lukashenko para crear
una crisis migratoria y me preguntaréis
pero tenemos certezas de que bielorrusia
esté ayudando de verdad a los migrantes
a llegar a la frontera pues atentos
vamos a ver repetir con el señor
lukashenko disimular es de débiles así
que ahora que ya sabéis en qué consiste
este plan maestro decirme quién podría
salir mal pues eso es lo que vamos a ver
ahora
[Música]
una nueva guerra híbrida
claro alomejor lukashenko estaba
convencido de que bruselas insistiría en
aceptar y repartir a los migrantes y
solicitantes de asilo que polonia se
opondría como ya lo hizo en el año 2016
y que con esto los bloques este y oeste
de la unión europea entrarían en una
guerra civil a muerte pero la verdad es
que la unión europea se ha mostrado
bastante más cohesionada de lo que el
propio lukashenko se esperaba la
comisión europea ha destinado 700 mil
euros a ayuda humanitaria y la cruz roja
ya está operando en la zona polonia y
letonia están reforzando las fronteras
aunque hay todavía mucho margen de
mejora pero de momento al menos la
situación se está descargando y esto es
así porque lo primero que ha hecho la
unión europea fue cortar el grifo a
migratorio por una parte hablaron con
los países de origen y de tránsito
presionando por ejemplo con quitarles la
ayuda al desarrollo y por otra parte
presionaron también a las compañías
aéreas amenazándoles con sanciones
comerciales si seguían trayendo
solicitantes de asilo a bielorrusia como
resultado países de tránsito como
existan turquía o emiratos árabes
unidos- empezaron a restringir los
vuelos a bielorrusia y además el
gobierno de irak ha empezado a poner
aviones para atraer a su gente de vuelta
cientos de migrantes regresan de irak en
un vuelo desde bielorrusia y os
preguntaréis y ya esta es una historia
muy concreta que ocurrido en bielorrusia
y no tiene ninguna repercusión para el
resto del mundo pues por sorprendente
que parezca esto de utilizar migrantes y
solicitantes de asilo como arma política
no es la primera vez que ocurre
lo hemos visto con turquía en 2015 y más
recientemente con marruecos en el caso
de turquía estaba en el camino de una de
las principales rutas migratorias
después de la guerra de siria y
precisamente por eso turquía pudo
imponer sus condiciones en el famoso
acuerdo migratorio del año 2016
básicamente anclará recibía fondos
europeos a cambio de controlar el acceso
a migrantes y solicitantes de asilo a la
unión europea hoy sigue siendo un
gatekeeper clave así que guste o no
bruselas tienen que contar con erdogán
pero este año en españa hemos visto
también una crisis migratoria en este
caso organizada por marruecos otro país
que actúa de filtro migratorio para
europa después de que fuera un líder
saharaui hospitalizado en logroño miles
de migrantes empezaron a llegar de
repente a la ciudad de ceuta como veis
los migrantes y solicitantes de asilo si
se utilizan para hacer presión en la
política internacional y vale
bielorrusia también es un país que tiene
frontera con la unión europea pero a
diferencia de turquía y marruecos
bielorrusia no está en medio de un flujo
migratorio
[Música]
si en algo coinciden el primer ministro
polaco y ursula von der leyen la
presidenta de la comisión europea es en
que lo de lukashenko es un intento de
orquestar una guerra híbrida con una
crisis migratoria completamente
artificial así que la pregunta es le ha
merecido la pena pues lo cierto es que
no vale que ha conseguido llamar la
atención de todo el mundo y salir en
todos los periódicos incluso ha hablado
dos veces con angela merkel pero aquí se
acaban las ventajas porque además habrá
que ver qué hace ahora con todos los
migrantes que no llegan a polonia pero
que tampoco vuelven a irak si se quedan
a vivir en minsk es muy probable que él
lukashenko se inunde a sí mismo con
todos esos solicitantes de asilo
evidentemente esto no tiene por qué ser
necesariamente malo para bielorrusia
pero sí puede traerle problemas
políticos
y pensar que a diferencia de la unión
europea- bielorrusia no tiene recursos
suficientes para integrar a todos esos
migrantes y tampoco tienen un mercado de
trabajo que les pueda absorber con
relativa fluidez veremos cómo se
desarrollan los acontecimientos en los
próximos meses pero todo apunta a que el
buen lukashenko quiso ser un
supervillano de película del 007 y se ha
quedado a la altura de un doctor maligno
pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
qué os ha parecido el plan maestro de
lukashenko conocéis más casos en los que
los migrantes sean utilizados como armas
políticas y cómo actuar y aix en este
caso si fueseis bruselas podéis dejarnos
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en
visual político sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribirse a
este canal y donde la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones tampoco olvidéis visitar
nuestro patrón si queréis apoyarnos y
recibir nuestra newsletter semanal si os
ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]